مديره حضانه شهيره بتعذب الاطفال وتسجيل
فضح جريمتها القصه
تقع غريبه من نوعها حرر فيها 10 اولياء
امور محضر ضد مديره حضانه شهيره بمحافظه
الاسكندريه بتهمه تعذيب اطفالهم وتعنيفهم
وضربهم
[موسيقى]
صرخه اولياء امور الصغار اجتاحت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بسرعه البرق بعد ما
وضحوا ان اطفالهم تعرضوا للضرب والتعنيف
من مديره حضانه بتتلقى مبالغ طائله شهريا
تصل لثلاثه الاف 150 جنيه للطفل الواحد
واكد الاهالي وجود كدمات وجروح في اماكن
متفرقه باجساد اطفالهم بلا اضافه للتعريف
والضرر النفس الكبير اللي تعرضوا له
[موسيقى]
بدورها اكتشفت ام عن تعرض بنتها البلاغه
من العمر 3 سنين انها تفاجات باتصال هاتفي
ورساله من معلمه سابقه في الحضانه بتؤكد
فيها تعرض بنتها للضرب على يد المديره
فضلا عن سوء تعامل العاملين مع الاطفال
واكدت انها استمعت لمقطع صوتي تعرفت فيه
على صوت بنتها وصرختها
ولجنه لازم
مش عايزه اقول لك ان
في مشيره الى امتلاكها دليل على تعرض
بنتها الصغيره للعنف خاصه ان صوت بكاءها
في التسجيل الصوتي واضح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واضافت ان الضرب تمثل بكدمات متتاليه على
جسمها وهو اللي دفعها لجمع اهالي اخرين
لفضح افعال المسؤوله ومعرفه حقيقه ما يحدث
لابنائهم داخل الحضانه
خالص
لما تقابلنا وابتدينا نتكلم اه ده ابني
كان بيجيء مخبوط اه ده بنتي حصل واحد
اثنين ثلاثه اه انا اثنين غريبه
الحضانه بتسجيل الصوتي اللي بيثبت تعرض
بنتها للضرب حيث ان التسجيل يتضمن تكرار
طلب المديره ان تطلب الصغيره دخول الحمام
باللغه الفرنسيه مع استمرار الطفله في
البكاء ورفضها الحديث فتزيد المديره الضرب
والتعنيف الاستاذ بيقول ايه
[موسيقى]
من وين
ولم يمر هذا التسجيل على رواد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي فكان بمثابه قاسيه على
قلب كل اللي سمعه واضافت الام انهم طلبوا
مديره الحضانه بتفريغ كاميرات المراقبه
فرفضت بدعوه انها لا تعمل مؤكده ان 10
اولياء امور حرروا محاضر ضد اداره الحضانه
واستمع تنيابه واقولهم
يشار الى ان المعلمه اللي سجلت الواقعه
اكدت كمان ان المديره خبطت راس طفل في
الحائط
وتسببت في اصابته بجرح في الراس
واخبرت والده ان احد زملائه دفعوه ليسقط
ارضا اثناء اللعب
كما روى بعض الاهالي ان المديره كانت
بتحرم الاطفال من الاكل والشرب فكانت بتضع
امام الاطفال الاكل وبتامرهم بعدم تناوله
واذا حاولوا الاكل بتضربهم
الاكل ما كانش عايز ياكل عشان تخليه ياكل
قعد الاولاد كلهم ياكلوا وهو يقعد معهم
ويحط اكل قدامه ويبقى جعان وما يمدش يده
في الاخر انها كانت بتهدد الاطفال علشان
ما يتكلموش عن اللي بيتعرضوا له وانها
كانت بتهديهم قبل ما اهلهم يجوا ياخذوهم
وبتاع يعني سؤال اي وليه امر عن الكدمات
ان دي اثار خطاه او لعبه اطفال مع بعض وقد
اثار الواقعه غضب واسع في الاوساط المصريه
عند عنيف الاطفال
شعرها لو ولد رجع انا على فكره انا اسفه
في اللي انا بقوله بس ده بجد ده حقيقي وده
كلام الناس اللي كان اللي جوه الحضانه لو
ولد
رجع وبالفعل تم القبض على مديره الحضانه
وحبسها اربع ايام على ذمه التحقيق ليهم
اهمها بالاعتداء على اطفال وتعريض حياتهم
للخطر وادارتها الحضانه قبل الحصول على
ترخيص بذلك